[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JOHN DOLHUN: Hello.
Good afternoon, everyone.
And welcome to the second
to the last lecture.
Next week, the X-ray
diffraction, Peter Mueller
will deliver that, I
believe, on Tuesday.
And this is the
mass spec lecture,
and then we'll keep you posted
as what happens in between.
There are a couple of
workshops for the oral reports,
and we'll also have a couple of
town hall meetings, one of them
being, I believe, next
week, next Thursday, which
will cover all three of the
labs that you're working on.
You can come here with your
questions and computers
and calculations, and all
the TAs and both instructors
will be here to help you
navigate through the third lab.
So today, I'm going to talk
about mass spectrometry.
And J.J. Thompson,
discoverer of the electron,
won the Nobel Prize in
1906 in physics, but not
for the discovery
of the electron,
for the conduction
of electricity
through various gases
and discharge tubes.
And then, after he
won that Nobel Prize,
seven members of his research
group won Nobel Prizes.
And then, in 1937, his
son won a Nobel Prize
for figuring out the wavelike
properties of the electron
that his father discovered.
Nine Nobel prizes in
one research group.
It's just amazing.
So J.J. went on to
build the first mass
spectrometer in 1912.
And in honor of him, we're going
to do a little electrical demo,
just to start off
with you today.
So what we're going
to be doing is
I'm going to be showing you
an incandescent light bulb.
And you all know them.
This is a big version.
This is the small version.
Inside of the incandescent light
bulb, there's the filament.
And they've used
tungsten since the turn
of the century, the turn
of the last century, 1906,
because tungsten has
the highest melting
point of all the metals.
Melts at around 3,400
degrees Celsius.
So inside of there, you
can see it in this bulb,
but I'm just going to turn
this on, just for a moment.
So you all know the
incandescent bulbs.
They get so hot.
When the electrons flow, they
flow through the circuit,
and then the tungsten atoms
start to vibrate inside
and it heats up to
about 2,200 degrees.
Have any of you ever
touched one of these?
You do it only one time
because they are so hot,
and that's why they're so
wasteful of electricity.
That's why we're going
to the LED lights today.
But what I've done
here is inside
of that light bulb
and this bulb,
there is an inert atmosphere.
There's argon and nitrogen
gases to protect that filament.
If they weren't in
there, I scratch my head
and I'd wonder what would
happen to that filament.
So what I did is
I took a bulb here
and I'm going to break one.
Hold your ears.
And out-- oh, beautiful.
The filament's
completely intact.
See, I didn't break it.
But I've already got one here
to show you this demo with.
So what we're
going to do is I am
going to take one of
these filaments outside
of the light bulb and I'm going
to turn on the electricity
and see what happens.
Let's turn the lights down now.
Yeah.
And he just shut
this light off here.
You ready?
AUDIENCE: Whoa.
JOHN DOLHUN: Wow,
didn't take long, right?
In the oxygen
atmosphere, the electrons
are flowing through there
and the tungsten atoms
are boiling off
with the electrons
and the thing just
disintegrates pretty instantly.
So I said to myself, I want
to do one more experiment.
And Amanda's going to
assist me with this.
We're going to fill this
beaker with liquid nitrogen
and we're going to take
one of these filaments
and we're going to stick it
down into the liquid nitrogen
and then we're
going to turn it on.
So think about
that for a minute.
What do you think
is going to happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Go ahead, Amanda.
I just blew one.
OK.
All right.
I ruined one, sorry.
I forgot this was on.
OK.
All right, let me turn
this off for a minute.
And I think I can put in
the one that I took out here
on the desk.
I'm going to put that one in
because the filament is intact.
OK, Amanda.
Just tighten it a bit.
Go ahead.
You OK?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHN DOLHUN: Liquid nitrogen,
minus 196 degrees Celsius.
Beautiful stuff.
Put your finger in there and
you know what's going to happen.
It's the skin effect.
Won't get you for the
first few seconds.
OK, good.
So here we go with
our experiment.
That's good, Amanda.
So we're going to
lower this down in.
Amanda, do you
want to hold this?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
JOHN DOLHUN: Just try
to get it in the center
and just lower it
all the way down in.
AUDIENCE: All the way?
JOHN DOLHUN: All the way.
Just go ahead.
Take it down.
Leave more slack.
Yeah.
Let it go down in.
OK, good.
Ready?
There it is in the liquid
nitrogen. Is it burning out?
AUDIENCE: No.
JOHN DOLHUN: No.
Take it out, Amanda.
Doesn't take long
in the air, does it?
So even the liquid nitrogen
is surrounding that filament
and protecting it.
And you've got the situation
where you don't have
the oxidation that's going on.
OK, so we take the
lights back up.
So in case you're
interested, tungsten it had--
anyone read Oliver Sacks
book, Uncle Tungsten?
It's a great book.
You've got to get that.
Tungsten plus oxygen
goes to tungsten oxide.
And you can
actually-- if you take
one of these filaments
that burned out,
you can actually see
the yellow-white powder
that from the tungsten
oxide that was left over.
So J.J. Thompson, because of
his discovery of the electron,
I wanted to show you
this electrical demo.
And now, we're going to get
into the mass spec, which
is pretty important
because you're
going to be using the mass
spec to characterize your ester
products in this lab.
So the inside of the mass spec
has several basic components.
You've got an area
outside here that
is at atmospheric pressure,
and the area inside that
is under a high vacuum.
Anyone have an idea why that
area is under a high vacuum
inside?
No?
So you're generating ions.
The ion are going to get
generated in this source.
The filament is going to shoot
electrons onto your molecule
and it's going to
ionize your molecule,
and then the molecule's
going to break apart.
And positive ions are
very short-lived species,
so we manipulate
them under vacuum.
And the vacuum--
the vacuum actually
is great because it
allows us to let the ion
have a mean-free pathway
from the ion source
to the detector without any
biomolecular collisions.
So the ions are
generated here and then
they go into the mass
analyzer and they're
sorted by their mass
to charge ratios,
and then they're
counted at the detector,
and out comes a spectrum.
You kind of get something
like this with abundance here
and the mass to charge ratio.
And depending on the
iron, so you might--
the detector may see a
lot of this, less of that
and less of that.
So you're going to get
vertical lines representing
the abundance of the ions that
were detected in that spectrum.
Each vertical line
represents an ion.
And we're talking about
mass to charge ratios,
the charges are usually plus 1.
So what we're looking
at in a mass spectrum
are the masses of
the individual ions.
Mass spec is-- the basic
principle of mass spec
is you have to have an ion
that enters the magnetic field
and it gets deflected.
It gets deflected dependent
on the actual mass to charge
ratio, how big that system is.
Bigger, heavier atoms
are going to be deflected
less than small, lighter atoms.
But that's the whole underlying
principle of mass spectrometry.
And now, I'm going to
talk about a couple
of the types of ionization.
Electron impact
is the basic form.
So what we have is
we've got our molecule
and we send it into
the ion source.
It gets bombarded by
electrons, and you
create an ionized
molecule, an M plus dot.
And this ionized molecule
can do one of two things.
This could break apart.
So the positive charge could
be retained on one part of it.
The radical would be
retained on the other.
So you could get
something like A plus
plus some radical given off.
Or it could break apart.
So one part retains both
the plus and radical.
So you could get
this type of ion
and a neutral
molecule given off.
What we detect with
mass spectrometry
is we're detecting these
daughter ions here.
These are the peaks we see.
We don't see the radicals
or the neutron molecules,
but we could figure them out
by subtracting the fragments
from the molecular weight.
And then we can-- we'll
know what's been lobbed off.
So if you have a
molecule like this,
it could ionize
anywhere in this chain.
And if it ionizes,
say, here, and then you
have a homolytic
cleavage of the bond,
you're going to get an R
prime CH 2 plus fragment,
and you'll get an
R2 CH2 radical.
So that's the idea.
Now, sometimes, some of
these bigger molecules,
these proteins and peptides, you
don't see molecular ion peaks
in the mass spectrum.
Even for some small molecules
you may not see them.
So we have another technique,
a softer ionization technique
called chemical ionization
that we can use.
So in chemical lionization,
what we do is we take a guess
and we flood the ion
source with a gas.
I'm going to choose
methane for this.
Methane is often use.
And we ionize that methane.
And then the ionized methane
reacts with more methane
to produce a super acid, CH5
plus, and a methyl radical.
Now, your molecule goes in and
it encounters the CH5 plus.
What do you think happens to it?
AUDIENCE: It's acidified?
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah, it's
going to get acidified.
It's going to get protonated.
So this CH5 plus
protonates your molecule,
and you get this
huge M plus 1 peak.
So this is great.
If we have these big
proteins and peptides
and we want to know what
the molecular weight is,
we can use chemical
lionization, put them in there,
and we'll see the big M plus 1.
We won't see a lot
of fragmentation,
but at least we can get some
molecular weight information
out of the system.
CH5 plus is an
interesting molecule.
You all know from your
chemical principles
that CH4 is SP3 hybridized.
So when those two
methane molecules collide
and it throws the
hydrogen in, that hydrogen
pushes another
hydrogen out of the way
and it forms a three-centered,
two-electron bond.
This is a pentavalent carbon
atom with a positive charge.
That's a carbocation.
That's the definition of a
carbocation in chemistry.
This is also called
the methanium ion.
And this is one of the last
unsolved problems in physics,
because no one can
isolate this stuff.
It's very difficult to isolate.
And about three years ago,
at the University of Cologne,
they actually trap some of
this stuff in an ion chamber
at very low temperatures,
near absolute zero,
and they studied the
vibrational spectra.
What they saw was
all these hydrogens
are coming off, moving
around the carbon atom.
They're breaking off
and moving around.
So now, scientists are wondering
whether this thing actually
has any structure at all.
So that's chemical ionization.
Sometimes, electron impact
and chemical lionization,
both of them won't work for us.
We may have a molecule
that's too big
or that's too nonvolatile.
So we go to fast atom
bombardment, electrospray,
or matrix-assisted laser
desorption spectroscopy.
Fast atom bombardment
is pretty simple.
You take your sample, mix it
with a little bit of glycerol,
put it on a metal
target, and then we
shoot xenon and
argon atoms at it,
very high speed, high energy.
And the glycerol in your
sample absorbs the shock
of the impact with those atoms.
And we have some
trifluoroacetic acid in there,
TFA, so that we can produce
these M plus 1 peaks.
The advantages of
fast atom bombardment
are for high molecular weight
samples, nonvolatile compounds,
EICI don't work.
Molecular weights here,
I've seen 20,000 or so.
So you can go out--
they're constantly making
innovations with these.
The next technique,
electrospray ionization,
is quite interesting.
The ions are produced,
the molecule is ionized,
and it's done at a very low pH.
And there's a nebulizer
that actually shoots out
like an aerosol
through a high voltage
and you get these charged
droplets coming out,
very large droplets with a lot
of positive charges on them.
And then we can take a
stream of warm nitrogen gas
and evaporate those down and you
get a smaller droplet and then
that disintegrates.
And what you end up with
are these multi-protonated
molecular ion peaks.
You could have an M plus 20.
You could have 20 hydrogens
on there, or 10 hydrogens,
or you get a variety of numbers.
And what that does is it
expands the mass range.
Let's say, for example, you have
a molecule that maybe weighs
70,000, and you produce a--
you produce an M plus 20.
So what you have to do is--
you're going to have
a molecule like that.
You're going to
have to divide, now,
by the charge to get where this
molecule is going to show up.
Because it's mass
to charge ratio,
and if the charge is 20,
if you divide this out,
you're going to get
something around 3,501.
That's where the peak is going
to show up in your spectrum.
So the advantage
of this technique
is you can take molecules
that are 70,000, 80,000,
and your peaks could come
out at 3,500 or much less.
So it expands the
whole mass range
of using a mass spectrometer.
The last technique is
MALDI, Matrix-Assisted Laser
Desorption Ionization, and
we would use that principally
for solids.
And these would be like the big
carbohydrates, the big peptides
and proteins.
And you take your crystal
and you dissolve it
in a matrix, a solvent, and
you put a chromophore in
to absorb the laser
light, and then
this sample begins to evaporate
and you get beautiful crystals
on this metal target.
And then you shoot a nitrogen
laser at it, 337 nanometers,
and you end up getting
M plus H speaks out.
So you can take
these large solids.
And molecular weights here
can go out quite a bit.
So the advantages of
all these techniques
are they can help us
with nonvolatile, high
molecular weight samples
and getting spectra.
We've already talked about
the inductively coupled plasma
in one of the lectures, so I'm
not going to talk about that.
But I would like to cover a
couple types of instruments
that you will experience.
The first is the
magnetic sector.
The last is the one we have
in the undergraduate lab,
the radio frequency
quadrupole filter trap.
So let's start with
the magnetic sector.
You'll see some
similarities to these.
So here is your ion source.
You can see the filament here.
And the filament is shooting
out an electron beam
at your sample.
It's about 70 electron volts.
That's like about
1,600 kcals of energy.
And 100 kcals, you
can break a bond.
So with all that energy
slamming into your molecule,
it not only ionizers
the molecule,
it starts to break
apart into fragments.
And the fragments in this
magnetic sector instrument
get ushered through a
pair of focal plates
and then they get sent
into the mass analyzer.
There's an electric
field perpendicular
to a magnetic field.
The electric field controls
the velocity of the ions,
and the magnetic field
will cause the deflection
with the heavier ions deflected
less than the lighter ions.
So you kind of get a spectrum
here on the detecting screen
based on how they're
deflected by the magnet.
Time of flight, this is
actually one of my favorites.
There are a couple
advantages to this.
One is it has almost an
unlimited mass range.
The second advantage is you can
do very small amounts of sample
with this.
So what happens
in time of flight
is your samples get ionized
in the ion source here.
They get ionized similar to all
the other mass spectrometers.
But then they get shot
out into a flight tube
and they get shot out at
the same kinetic energy,
all the ions that
are going in there.
And kinetic energy is equal to
1/2MV squared, which is also
proportional to the
charge times the voltage
when they're being shot out.
So if you look at
the kinetic energy,
you can see that the
velocity is square root of 2
of the kinetic energy
divided by the mass.
So that means that the heavy
ions are kind of lagging here.
They're traveling slower
because they're heavier.
So when they're in this
tube, they actually
measure the time of
flight through the tube.
That's what this-- it's
called time of flight, right?
So the time of flight
is the distance
divided by the velocity.
Now, if you put that back
into this equation and you
solve it out, you'll see
that the mass to charge ratio
is equal to the square
of the time of flight
divided by the distance.
This is a great salute
to the engineers.
They designed this system.
This machine is so simple.
There's no electric field.
There's no magnetic field.
All there is is a tube.
Doesn't this remind you
of TLC with the spots?
Except there's no mobile phase
and no stationary phase here,
right?
So this is a great instrument.
And that's how your mass
spectrum is determined.
Now, the next one,
which is also kind
of like the Cadillac of
all mass spectrometers,
is the Fourier-transform ion
cyclotron resonance instrument.
This instrument, ions are
generated the same way
as in the other
mass spectrometers,
but when they're
generated, they start
to get pumped to different
pumping stations,
and every pumping station has
a higher and higher vacuum.
So the pressures
continue to drop
until the ions reach this box,
and then everything breaks
loose here.
Because in this box,
you've got a temperature
of about 2 Kelvin.
You've got a magnetic
field of about 21 tesla,
and there's an electric
field in there.
And if you think about this,
you have a charged particle
traveling at a certain
velocity and it enters--
it enters the magnetic field.
What happens to it?
What's going to happen to
that charged particle when it
gets into that magnetic field?
Autumn?
AUDIENCE: It'll go around.
JOHN DOLHUN: It's going
to start to spin, yeah,
like a cyclotron.
It's going to be-- it's going
to be spinning like this.
In fact, when the
particle goes in there--
let me give you an example, like
100 molecular weight fragment,
100 Dalton could
travel 30 meters
in about one second inside
of that box just crazy.
So it has a centripetal
force on it.
And force is mass times
acceleration, right?
So mass times acceleration.
So this is our system.
And the angular velocity
of that particle
is given by velocity over r.
So if you plug that in here,
the cyclotron frequency
of that particle, that
velocity is nothing
to do with its velocity.
It's only to do with
mass and charge.
That's the bottom line.
That's incredible.
And if we hold the
magnetic field constant,
then the cyclotron
frequency is the mass
to charge ratio
of that particle.
So what comes out of
this is convoluted
signals like this
FID, these sine waves,
and we do a Fourier-transform
on that signal
and pull out the mass
spectrum that we want.
So it's quite interesting.
It's the most sensitive method
of ion detection in the world.
The resolution is greater than
10 to the 7 on this instrument.
And if you think about it,
that spinning particle,
it's spinning so many times,
the detector is on the outside
here.
The difference between this and
all other forms of mass spec is
the detector is on the outside,
so it doesn't-- the ions never
reach the detector.
They only record the image
current from the ions
as they're going by.
And it's recording it over
and over and over again.
That's why you've got such
beautiful resolution here.
And then you've got
the system we're
going to use, the quadrupole
filter radio frequency system.
So what we have for
our mass analyzer
is four rods in parallel,
and the opposite rods
are electrically connected.
There's a DC voltage
put on those rods.
And then an RF voltage is
superimposed on one pair
of rods over the other.
And it's the voltage of
that pulsed radio frequency
field and the frequency
that determines which
ions get through these rods.
Only one ion can actually make
it through the rods at a time,
depending on the frequency
of that radio frequency pulse
and the ratio of
voltages on those rods.
And the other ions basically
just crash into the sides here.
So a couple of things, before
you actually come in the lab
and do the lab, we
have to actually
tune the mass spectrometer up.
Because mass spectrometers
have an internal mass scale.
Can actually go off kilter.
And so we've got to make
sure that every mass is
where it's supposed to be.
The detector gain has to
be cranked up so that we
can see peaks far enough out.
To do that, we
use this compound,
perfluorotributylamine.
This is the stuff
that we actually
have in the mass spectrometer
in a little vessel,
and when we do the tune,
the vessel opens up,
and a whiff of this comes out.
And the beauty of this is
it can fragment down here.
ScF3 can fall off.
You get a 69 peak.
Can do that from
three directions.
You can lose one of these
polyfluorinated butyl groups
from either of three directions
and you get a 219 peak,
or you can clip it right
here and you get a 502 peak.
And that's pretty
much all you see.
You see the 69, the
219, and the 502.
The spectrum is very simple.
And the molecular weight is 502.
So
We key in on these and
adjust the internal mass
scale of the instrument
and make sure
it can separate
peaks 1 AMU apart.
And for your
samples, your samples
will be under molecular
weight of 200.
So if we can go out to
500 and have it tuned up,
we'll be fine.
This is water.
Very simple molecule.
This is your chance to talk.
I want you to--
we're going to
actually look at this.
What I'd like to do
is I'd like to see
what the mass spectrum
of water looks like.
So we're going to
ionize some water.
And we've got our abundance here
and our mass-to-charge ratio.
So what would you see in
the mass spectrum of water?
Which peaks would you see?
Royce?
Oh, you were
scratching yourself.
Yeah.
[CHUCKLES] What would you see?
Yes, Alec?
AUDIENCE: M-to-C equals 18.
JOHN DOLHUN: 18, yes.
You'd definitely see an 18 peak.
That's your ionized
water molecule.
What else?
Alec?
There's not much to
fragment, is there?
Well, what would you get
if you tore this apart?
AUDIENCE: You'd get a 1.
JOHN DOLHUN: A 1, yes, you'd
definitely see a 1 here.
That's your hydrogen. What else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You might see a 16.
JOHN DOLHUN: Yep,
you'd see a 16.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Will you see a 17?
JOHN DOLHUN: Yes, you would.
Very good.
And that is-- that's the whole
spectrum of water, four peaks.
Yes, Autumn.
AUDIENCE: Could you get 32 or
2 in the oxygen and hydrogen
diagrams?
JOHN DOLHUN: You could get--
if you're looking at air,
air has diatomic gases in it.
So if you put air in, you would
see some of those peaks, yeah.
Yeah, let's look at air,
since you mentioned that.
Let me just put this down here.
I mean, air has diatomic gases.
So what would you see in air?
Yeah, Noah.
AUDIENCE: A 28.
JOHN DOLHUN: A 28, good.
So you'd see a 28 here.
Yep, what else?
AUDIENCE: 32.
JOHN DOLHUN: Yep,
you'd see a 32.
AUDIENCE: 44.
JOHN DOLHUN: Very good.
Good old carbon dioxide.
Yep.
What else?
AUDIENCE: 18.
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah,
you'd see water.
We hate water, but
it's in the air, right?
So you definitely, definitely
would see an 18 peak.
What else?
How about some of
the noble gases?
They're in the air.
Which one?
AUDIENCE: Ne.
JOHN DOLHUN: Neon, yeah.
Neon is 20.
Any others?
AUDIENCE: Would you see argon?
JOHN DOLHUN: Yes, argon.
Argon is 40.
What other gas?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Would you
see helium or not?
JOHN DOLHUN: Very little.
Very little.
What else?
What's a couple of the
other big inert gases?
AUDIENCE: Xenon?
JOHN DOLHUN: Xenon, yes, 131.
What about the Superman gas?
AUDIENCE: Oh, krypton.
JOHN DOLHUN: Krypton, yes.
84, krypton.
And you may see a 29
peak, because you might
see nitrogen-15, nitrogen-14.
Because the mass spec
will detect isotopes.
You also, for oxygen,
you could see a 34 peak,
because you've got-- you might
have some oxygen-18, oxygen-16.
But you've hit them.
And these just came out--
this was I think in not Time
magazine, but one of the--
one of the magazines came
out with the periodic table.
The whole issue was
on the periodic table.
And they listed all the
gases that are in the air.
So it's kind of neat.
So let's move on here.
I want to show you what a
mass spectrum looks like.
This is hexane, your
good old friend, right?
C6H14.
So what you've got here is
you've got your molecular ion
peak at 86, right?
And then everything to the left
of that is fragments breaking--
the molecule breaking apart.
And notice the
intensity of the peaks.
One of the peaks is a base peak.
That means the detector counted
that more than any other peak.
So what the detector
does is gives
that 100 and all the other peaks
are relative to that base peak.
And when we give you
your mass spectrum,
we'll give you a sheet
with the abundances on it.
Notice, if you take
this base peak, 57,
and you subtract it from 86,
that's a loss of 29, isn't it?
So it's pretty much just an
ethyl radical falling off,
and you've got
this butyl cation.
The butyl group has
the plus charge.
That's your 57 peak.
It's that simple.
So you take your peak, subtract
from the molecular ion,
see what's been thrown off.
What about the m
plus 1 peak here?
What is that?
There's no chemical
ionization going on here.
[CHUCKLES] What's
the m plus 1 peak?
Yes, Deb.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Did you say
something with carbon?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, 13.
JOHN DOLHUN:
Carbon-13, very good.
Yeah, carbon-13.
So carbon-13 has an
abundance of 1.1%.
1.1% of all carbon is carbon-13.
Look up here.
You got six carbons, right?
So 6 times that--
6.6% of the carbons
are carbon-13.
So if I take this molecular
ion peak, which is--
my eye is saying it's
about 15% abundance,
if I multiply that by 0.066,
I get 1%, that m plus 1 peak.
That's approximately
what we're talking about.
What if we didn't know
the number of carbons?
We didn't know the structure?
We could work backwards
and figure it out
from the molecular ion abundance
and the m plus 1 abundance.
The number of carbons would
be equal to the abundance
of the m plus 1 divided
by the abundance of the m
plus dot times 100
divided by 1.1.
That would give you the number
of carbons in your molecule.
So mass spec can not only
determine the molecular weight,
you can determine the molecular
formula of your system.
You can also determine the
number of isotopes and elements
that are present in your system.
So there are other isotopes.
Look at chlorine-35
and chlorine-37 here.
If you see this in the molecular
ion region of your spectrum,
and your molecular ion is
separated by 2 mass units,
it's a dead giveaway.
That's chlorine's signature.
That means you have a
chlorine in your molecule.
Bromine is even simpler.
Bromine has two peaks,
both equal abundance--
the 79 and the 81
separated by 2 mass units.
Here's an example.
So here's a mass spectrum.
Look at our molecular
ion region here,
separated by 2 mass
units, ratio of 3 to 1.
What do we have?
AUDIENCE: Chlorine.
JOHN DOLHUN: A chlorine, yes.
OK?
So if you take this--
take this peak here,
this is 77, subtract 112,
you have a loss of 35.
So if you take the--
if you simply take the two
things and put them together,
the 77 is the phenyl ion.
So if you just stick
a chlorine on there,
you got chlorobenzene.
That's the spectrum.
Here's another spectrum.
This is very interesting,
because all these peaks
are separated by methylene
units, 14 mass units, CH2
units, all through
the whole spectrum.
When you see that,
you know you've
got a long chain of carbon
atoms as part of your spectrum.
So this particular
spectrum is decane.
And it ionizes at all
these different bonds,
producing this spectrum with
this logical lost ion series.
There's another one,
dodecanoic acid,
which has all these
methylene units, which
is a dead giveaway for a long
chain of carbons connected
to something.
Here is a simple spectrum.
This is 2-propanol.
Now, the molecular
weight of this is 60.
But look down here.
Do you see 60?
There's no molecular ion there.
So this molecule
is doing something
that's energetically
very favorable to itself
to produce a 59 peak.
What do you think it's doing?
It's one less than the
molecular ion, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's losing
the H on the OH.
JOHN DOLHUN: Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's losing
the H on the OH.
JOHN DOLHUN: Yes, Hannah.
Loses the H, right.
So if you take--
this guy ionizes here.
And it has resonance,
because you
can throw that positive
charge out onto the oxygen.
So it's really, really
a very stable system.
It loves to do that.
And look at the base peak
in this spectrum, 45.
You can lose a methyl group
from either side here,
and you've got a 45.
It's left over.
And it's resonance-stabilized,
because the positive charge can
resonate with this oxygen here.
So that's the idea.
When you see a
base peak, you know
the molecule is
loving to do something
that's very favorable.
And in this case, it could
cleave from two sides.
So this is an ester.
This is ethyl-isobutyrate.
I don't know if this is
one that's been given out.
I'm not talking.
But this is a simple spectrum.
And the idea here
is, what you do
is you're going to
take this, and you're
going to break it apart
to try to figure out where
those peaks are coming from.
So if you cleave the ester here,
right, right by this carbonyl,
you lose this--
do this alpha cleavage,
you'll get this 71 fragment,
which can then lose carbon
monoxide to give you
a 43 fragment.
So if we actually go back
here, there's our 71,
and there's our 43.
And then, look at
this right here.
You can actually lose a
neutral molecule of ethylene.
Transfer the hydrogen
back to this point.
And you're losing CH2-CH2.
That's an example where
one piece of the molecule
retains both the plus charge
and radical that I talked about.
And here's your
fragment, your 88.
There it is there.
So the idea is to go through
here and try to take your ester
and try to break it
up and substantiate
some of the fragments from--
in a table or something, to
show that what you've got.
And that way-- that way you'll
convincingly convince someone
that you-- indeed
that is your product.
Do you have some
questions about this?
So if you're on day four,
you'll be doing the mass spectra
today.
And I guess you turn in your
guesses for your unknowns
today, right?
Good.
It was easy, right?
Yes.
It was too easy, wasn't it?
AUDIENCE: Nah.
[CHUCKLING]